welcome to this video playing jerome
here with white let's get this going
it's two and a half out of four and a
half against him yeah let's switch back
to my samish variation this sharp line
they've played a lot in the past I've
searched a little bit to the classical
and recent games just wanting some
variety but let's return to to this Oh
interesting 90 exit sir but I'll come on
down can even go see for in this
position maybe 93 Quincy to let's try
that it's not how I usually play this
but interesting so just know i have
three here
yeah white has a good central control
him didn't want to take that on on c5
but this idea comes into into the plane
um in case of black oops what's this I
can go d5 now don't understand to move
on t5 can also take it which is not bad
but let's think about the fire for a
moment like g5 what is she doing queen
sorry night a590 takes a five and then
some kind of tactic on I don't get it
now let's see I also could have taken
wouldn't have been bad it goes there was
thinking Queen 85 a Knight a5 at least
two trying to get some kind of
compensation I mean this is really just
a pawn down and I have a big center in
addition okay taking it and then if all
it's a simple way
orbis should be to first maybe we should
be to first that's not bad chair one day
for maybe a for him and yep let's go a4
a5 trying to make sure that nothing is
popping up on a4ai wants to go to this
60 so I can go Quinn's Queen to see
three or something like that yeah maybe
let's do that it's not a bad bad setup
96 probably and after 96 I even have
fish should be five okay yeah okay if I
can if I can play a 5 i'm going to do
that
getting rid of the somewhat weakish a
pawn yeah Quincy 3 now was my idea
provoking f6 which looks pretty ugly
then a 45 yep 9065 is very nice Mads
it's very good for white don't really
see how we can try to defend this
why just em I just push it through here
in the center opening on the diagonal
Tim yeah the rook is also hanging um can
I just take the rook there that's
probably easiest am just taking it black
resigns yeah it's an opening disaster I
don't know that this looks a bit 95
looks a bit strange here to be honest
giving why this the center so easily
it's a number of good options even I
mean it's not threatening on c3 as I
always have bishop h7 Quincy to check 9f
392 the Royal interesting but I was
thinking that this is an interesting way
to play putting see far out we should be
too quickly yeah here castles and I
really don't know what he's doing now
it's a bit of a problem to untangle
there he cannot play Bishop d7 them I'm
taking then and you have to go back and
this is just terrible really I mean it's
a pawn and away the black's pieces are
completely ridiculous so he cannot
cannot play Bishop d7 and I don't know
how he develops this now those nights
are not not really coordinated the
computer suggests the really wacky
looking move f5 yeah maybe maybe
something like that putting at least
something in the center it looks very
weakening though by five okay you did
this and after d5 hmm I thought you
would go here and after this I'm some
move I don't know attacking the knight
and trying to take C form but it's I
don't really know how we should attack
Adele six queen age five is probably
pretty bad pretty bad as a good
euphemism is just winning ok this is
also so not on yeah it just is just bad
what can you do just win this pawn
and have excellent control the a4 a5 now
yep and I think from he had some many
many possible option I could have taken
g6 even I just see that but if all is
good here be 45 is just wrong open opens
up everything and in this particular
case there's even this this double check
i didn't see that initially I just
wanted to open up the diagonals but it's
even stronger than that due to this
direct tactical liability okay well
thanks for watching